last question today is from Kendra do
you rehearse phone calls before you make
them this is so funny I know a lot of
people who before they make a phone call
they sort of think through the script of
what they're going to say and I'm
talking about a phone call to you know
ask a technical support question to your
mobile phone provider or if you're
calling to cancel an appointment or if
you're leaving a voicemail for someone
or whatever some people will even sort
of like make notes I never do that I
rarely even think about it I just call
and if I end up having to leave a
voicemail I'll just sort of think about
it on the fly or if I speak to someone I
am NOT someone to rehearse phone calls I
don't know if it has to do with because
I host the show I just call and I figure
it out as I go along but that's not
something I've ever done I know many
people who do that though you could hang
up the phone at any point and there's
not an anonymity where they don't even
know who you are not always though not
always I you your dentist office or
something you're going to see those
people again that's true yeah I used to
have this fear especially when it came
to like ordering food and I was
particularly young yeah but later I got
a job at a pizza shop and I realized
that most people have no idea what
they're talking about and also I used to
prank called a pizza shop while I was
working there so that built up my
confidence and now I'm completely okay
with making a call former producer Louis
and I used to make prank phone calls
when we were younger and they were all
set like the premises were never that
clever okay but that might have also
increased my comfort level on the phone
to some degree yeah I used to ask for
toppings that they didn't have I used to
ask for things like a meatlovers pizza
without me sure and you know all these
funny accents and everything I think
that is something I would recommend to
building up your confidence so then you
can make phone calls with relative ease
but the funny thing is to me that
ordering food is when I would actually
work off of a script in a sense which is
like the list of items I'm going to be
ordering that I think are it actually
does make sense to have something
written down but some of those things
are so easy like you know if it's a
pickup or delivery you know what your
name is yes I don't need to write that
down obviously good do you have like
standard orders for types of restaurants
like for you know have some people if
they order from a Chinese restaurant
doesn't matter what restaurant it is or
whatever they know their items so you
don't even really have to write it down
like do you have specific items that you
order yeah
have the usual and usually I'm taking
out certain things and putting in other
different things that's my usual if only
they knew
give us one item that's like a standby
in your Chinese restaurant orders in a
Chinese okay so vegetable lo mein
noodles okay a vegetarian delight with
tofu so uh and white rice white rice
white rice but my god
well isn't brown rice also I don't they
do what place are you ordering from that
the brown rice is extra geez yeah I mean
for me I love scallion scallion pancakes
so that's a common thing that I'll order
at Chinese restaurants although at some
places they're just soggy they're not
crispy and there's nothing worse than a
soggy scallion pancakes sometimes at a
Mexican place I'll take out the cheese
and sour cream and then I demand them
give me more guacamole because normally
they would charge extra for that but if
I'm taking two things off they're saving
money right I'm just making up the
difference well guacamole is more
expensive isn't it than yes but then
give me that proportional amount extra
that you're saving off of the cheese is
out right there's some ratio I'm sure
we're like for every tablespoon of
cheese that you take off yeah like
two-thirds of a tablespoon of guacamole
is the equivalent cost or something like
that I'm sure the person on the make
line would have no issues with a crowded
line of people taking a break and
pulling out their calculator and their
port protractor to certain Japanese
restaurant any standard order that you
have at amount you seem like an unabomb
a guy I know then yeah I know what that
is but I'm not much of a Japanese
restaurant attendee all right well
listen enough about Pat okay
no Kendra I do not rehearse phone calls
before I make them but it's an
interesting idea and I appreciate you
writing in about that it led to quite a
conversation we've got a huge bonus show
for you today david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up the coupon code
I voted 17 still works and it will still
save you 40% off of your membership and
don't forget patreon even if it's a
dollar a month do it patreon.com slash
david pakman show speak to you on the
bonus show